wischmeyer sorgt buch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten vier jahre jamaika vier
parteien für besserverdiener die im
osten keine sau kennen das wird ein spaß
hier meine prognose kurz vor weihnachten
einigen sich grüne und csu endlich auf
eine obergrenze und zwar liegt die bei
genau 1 meter 90 pro flüchtling mehr
geht einfach nicht im januar bestätigt
tatsächlich das ende des
verbrennungsmotors
zum abschied gibt es nochmal eine
sonderauflage des beliebten saugt
diesels der euronorm 0 in einer
limitierten edition von 60 millionen
stück die grünen fordern außerdem den
ausstieg aus der kernkraft bis
spätestens 2020
außerdem soll die ehe für alle auf
sämtliche säugetiere erweitert werden
aber nur wenn diese freiwillig mitmachen
und vorher duschen der tod auf verlangen
ist in der koalition weiter strittig
während die grünen meinen der sterbende
soll selbst über sein ende entscheiden
fordert die csu eine abstimmung im
familienkreis kurz gesagt lauter geile
ideen und auch ein jamaika kabinett
zeichnet sich bereits ab
hier die highlights wegen ihrer achten
schwangerschaft wechselt flinten okay
von der leyen vom
verteidigungsministerium ins kanzleramt
und zwar als kammerzofe von angela
merkel
an der spitze der bundeswehr erfolg der
langhaarige sanitäts gefreite anton
hofreiter der ersten panzerdivision aus
oldenburg desertiert im november nach
verlangt wolfgang kubicki bekommen das
neu gegründete ministerium für
selbstbräuner hochprozentiges und geile
weiber karl theodor zu guttenberg ist
als wissenschaftsminister gesetzt bis
herauskommen dass er seine
geburtsurkunde gefälscht hat sein
richtiger name lautet klaus bärbel zu
guten ja der treitz baron von mogel
achja ministerin für umwelt und
reaktorsicherheit wird natürlich sophia
thomalla logisch aber es gibt auch gute
nachrichten
cem özdemir kriegt das auswärtige amt
wie lustig ist das denn die leute die
weg überfremdungsängste gewählt haben
kriegen zur belohnung einen
türkischstämmigen außenminister das
beweist es gibt doch ein gott
beziehungsweise allahu akhbar kameraden
weitermachen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich war damals ja
[Applaus]